[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan Fitzpatrick who joins us we have
the Niners and the Giants coming up uh
Thursday night Thursday night football
and Ryan of course uh one of the
analysts there on the program the Prime
video starts at 8 15 Eastern Thursday
Night Football tonight all right is it
in your contract that you must keep your
beard
so I don't think it's written in the
contract although it was mentioned to me
that it was a very important thing that
I kept my beard
um so I I am not shaving it I also just
funny anecdote was doing a commercial
and they were nervous I shaved my chest
hair
so they had Yak hair
just in case I shaved my chest hair
because I was going to be a big part of
the commercial they put Yak hair on your
chest for the commercial
yeah let me see
I got it in here somewhere it's in my
trophy case but just in case they had it
on set because they were nervous that I
would shaving my chest okay
well is it part of your identity though
do you feel like that if you did shave
does that take away something from you
yeah I mean I could go I could be
completely Anonymous if I shave my beard
I don't think people would recognize me
but uh you know my kids are kind of the
driving force behind it now my daughters
have no interest they've seen me shave
my beard once or twice and have no
interest ever seeing that man again
wow all right that's all we needed to
know Ryan you know have a great game
tomorrow night uh we were just talking
about the Hall of Fame Dion has brought
this up before could you have a a top
floor
that will distinguish differentiate the
first ballad Hall of Famers so you make
it it's special for the Hall of Fame now
you get something that's even more
special for guys who are first ballot
Hall of Famers what do you think of that
idea
I think it's a great idea
you know it's going to be interesting
coming up here
just the way that the stats have blown
up in the last 15 years especially with
quarterback play uh when the Richard
Sherman and I love to have these debates
all the time of you know is he a first
ballot guy is he going to get in the
Hall of Fame but if you strictly look at
numbers of some of these guys you're
looking at Matt Ryan's numbers you're
looking at Matthew Stafford's numbers uh
now Russell Wilson the first one to ever
do what he did with the passing yards
and the rushing yards and he's got a
Super Bowl under his belt it's like how
many of these guys are we looking at
that were saying well gosh I guess I
could see him getting in the Hall of
Fame uh I think I think making a tear or
a distinction is a good idea Matthew
Stafford Hall of Famer
he's one of my favorite quarterbacks
I've ever watched but I I just think
there were too many empty years in
Detroit okay Matt Ryan
I I think if he wins that Super Bowl it
becomes very easy but I mean Matt Ryan
statistically I don't have it in front
of me but I think he's probably top five
in yards
in his career or somewhere up there so
um he had some pretty good years in
Atlanta I would say yes
he's got 63 000 yards
yeah that's I mean I'm telling you some
of these discussions are going to happen
with these quarterbacks coming up uh
it's going to be very difficult uh it's
going to be difficult to get in but it's
going to be difficult to say no to a lot
of these guys with their numbers can
Russell Wilson play himself out of the
Hall of Fame
yes is he playing himself out of the
yes I think he is uh that's going to be
an interesting one this week too at
Miami
um
or I don't know if they're they're
playing Miami but who's whose fault is
that going to be as that continues to go
south is that Sean Payton or is that
wristband Russell I think we're uh we're
all intrigued on that one
but I don't know what happened like how
does it you go from being this you know
Hall of Fame quarterback unbelievable
career and then all of a sudden you fall
off you know the cliff here what what
happens
yeah I mean I think
sometimes
you don't know how good you have it
until until it's gone and that was a
historic defense in Seattle
um that was a great situation that he
was put in look and he played really
well and you know
it just as soon as this whole let rust
cook thing happened and he wanted to go
to another place because he wants to
have more control and show that he can
do it somewhere else
the grass is not always greener and I
think this is a situation that
definitely points to that
talking to Ryan Fitzpatrick you can see
him tomorrow night it'll be Amazon Prime
video Andrew Whitworth Tony Gonzalez uh
let's see who else oh my good uh good
friend Chris Thompson is going to be
there Richard Sherman is going to be
their pre-half time and post game show
coverage at seven Eastern the games at 8
15. I know you played in uh the ivy
league buddy Stevens the great Dartmouth
head coach just passed away it was quite
the innovator I don't know if you uh you
know what your recollection was of uh a
buddy at Dartmouth
yeah uh we lost a great man I mean he
did great things for Dartmouth for the
ivy league and really for the game of
football in general and uh he was best
friends with my coach Tim Murphy and so
I got to know him over the years he ran
the Peyton uh and Eli Manning Passing
Academy so he meant a lot to the game of
football and even just health and safety
of the players some Innovative things
they did at Dartmouth so I appreciate
you for bringing that up and we
certainly lost a great man yeah we had
him on a couple of times he was a great
interview and uh really an innovator
ahead of his time with uh college
football at Dartmouth I was wondering
about this strategy Brian dabel is
saying saquon Barkley could be available
tomorrow night and I was wondering about
that I don't know if it's gamesmanship
but it also puts a little more pressure
on saquon Barkley that
you know he's supposed to be out three
weeks now your coach is saying hey you
might be available tomorrow night so
then what maybe it's you are you why
aren't you playing because your coach is
saying this is Brian just saying do you
expect saquon Barkley to play tomorrow
night
well as an employee and analyst for
Amazon I fully
um but you know watching watching the
end of that game
um and the way you know his expression
his frustration his face the way that
the ankle got tweaked there's no chance
he's playing in this game it's it's
gamesmanship it's stable just making
sure that they have to still prepare a
little bit uh for saquon if he plays but
I I don't think anybody believes that
and and so that doesn't put a whole lot
of pressure on sake one because I think
it's just the coach talking now once you
apply a timetable to him and you say
okay this is a mild ankle sprain three
weeks that as a player is tough because
there's now undue pressure on you to
hurry up and get back on the field and
as players we're trying to do the best
we can to be out there and be available
did you ever face somebody who was in
that category with Micah Parsons
uh he is
unbelievable I think there were some
years you know J.J watt there were some
years where he was unblockable Aaron
Donald unblockable uh but Micah Parsons
is quickly becoming
the guy the face of the NFL uh it's
really scary and I think Dan Quinn is so
Innovative in the way that he's gonna be
able to put him in different spots in
Russian because look a lot of an offense
and what you do what can you do versus a
great pass rusher well you could chip
but all of a sudden we saw last week
they put my compartments on the outside
they run a game where he steps up and
then runs around and to the inside so
they know how teams are going to try to
block Micah they're going to move him
around it's hard to double him on every
play but he's as good as it gets and he
is a scary scary player right now I
didn't understand the Jets philosophy
here the game plan you have Zach Wilson
on the road against Dallas and you run
the ball 11 times you have two good
running backs why not just you know Bill
Parcells used to say the best way to go
at a great defender is to go at the
defender don't let him try to catch up
with the play because LT Micah Parsons
they have the athleticism to do it
why not just run the football and take
away a little bit of the pressure of
Zach Wilson
yeah sometimes you know it's a head
scratcher but you know I'm sure that was
the intent going into the game that's
what they wanted to do
as the score gets away from you a little
bit
um you know as you're trying to play
this game of catch up and figure out as
you're getting behind the chains okay
what are we doing here what are we doing
here uh it just gets difficult as a play
caller did they want Breeze Hall to
touch the ball four times no I mean I
think we saw the week before what they
want briefs Hall to be they want a
healthy dose a breeze a healthy dose of
Dalvin cook take some pressure off of
young Zack Wilson but it's it's
difficult sometimes when you get in
those games because you go in with one
plan and then all of a sudden you look
back after the game and think gosh you
know we really screwed up here but a lot
of that is you know a play caller trying
to look at that scoreboard and make up
points when
you can't really uh put it all on Zach
Wilson when you heard that the Niners
were going to reach out to Philip Rivers
if they had made the Super Bowl with the
injuries to their quarterbacks
now did you think that maybe you could
volunteer did they call you to see if
you wanted if if you could have been
able to play
last year if they had gone to the Super
Bowl did they contact you or did you
think about reaching out to them
no uh they did not contact me and I did
not think about reaching out but
um you know I the Philip Rivers thing is
interesting with a with a quarterback
you know with the with the receiver with
the running back
you can't really just come off the
street after missing 15 16 weeks of NFL
season then into the playoffs and play
as a quarterback that might be the one
position kicker do we count them I don't
know that you could actually do it I
don't know what kind of shape Philip was
in but he's so sharp up here uh that
that probably would have been the best
option
what if the Jets called you to be a
backup for Zach Wilson
no chance
um physically you know I had a hip
injury the end of my career I don't know
where I'd be with that but I love what
I'm doing right now with Amazon uh love
my family life you know I gave
17 years of my life fully committed to
the game of football and with that
became a lot of sacrifices away from my
family and so I'm perfectly content at
what I'm doing right now and absolutely
loving being involved with Amazon and
getting to do the Thursday night gig so
I'm I'm happy where I am so no chance
what's the coolest thing in your office
there
well I'd say the chest here but one of
the kids must have uh grabbed it maybe
they're wearing it to school
um
you know I've got you
I've got a a lot of cool stuff let me
grab one real fast hold on okay talking
to Ryan Fitzpatrick this was my Thursday
night game
this was my childhood helmet that I used
to wear throwing the ball in the front
yard
uh and it just so happened that in 2005
with the 250th pick this was also the
first NFL team I ever played for so that
one is pretty neat for me it looks like
something on the that the Brady Bunch
may have worn the Rams helmet that uh
they wore yeah
it actually it doesn't fit anymore
either I don't want to mess up my hair
yeah your hair looks good hair looks
good thank you what's my TV hair yeah no
no you did great job there uh we'll be
watching tomorrow night always great to
talk to you thank you for your opinions
and uh have a great day
all right thank you we'll see you that's
Ryan Fitzpatrick you can see him
tomorrow night seven Eastern is when
they start Thursday Night Football
tonight kickoff at Prime video at 8 15
Easter